Speaker 1: So many of you wrote to me over the
weekend and said, David, can it be can it really
be that a Trump appointed judge is going to be
involved in overseeing Trump's own indictment?
Tell me it's not going to happen because
that seems so biased and disastrous. Well,
it is part of the story, and I want to talk about
it with you today. The New York Times reports a
Trump appointed judge who showed him favor gets
the documents case, a surprise assignment of Judge
Eileen Cannon. Could be a setback for prosecutors
as they unveiled a sweeping classified files
indictment. A judge can in 42. A Trump appointee
shocked legal experts across ideological lines
last year by intervening in the investigation
and issuing rulings favorable to Mr. Trump,
only to be rebuked by a conservative appeals
court. The chief clerk of the courts in Florida
Southern District has said that the that new
cases there are randomly delegated to its judges,
even if they are related to previous ones. It was
not immediately clear whether Mr. Trump lucked
out or if an exception was made. Either way,
legal specialists said Judge Cannon's return
was significant, was significant for those
asking the question. Slate has a very good
piece by Mark Joseph Stern. Judge Eileen Cannon
can absolutely sink the federal prosecution of
Trump. And this reads The federal criminal case
against Donald Trump for mishandling classified
documents will be overseen, at least initially
and initially by Judge Eileen Cannon. This is
excellent news for Trump and exceedingly
bad news for special counsel Jack Smith.
Cannon's total lack of discipline, combined
with her evident incapacity to experience shame,
renders her a uniquely favorable jurist
for the former president. Indeed,
if she maintains her grasp on this case, it is
nearly impossible to envision Smith securing a
conviction in her courtroom. This is, of course,
the opinion, the opinion of Mark Joseph Stern.
This command marked the first time in history, in
the history of the republic that a federal judge
had claimed the power to stop a pre indictment
criminal investigation into a suspect. Cannon's
previous overreach provoked genuine shock in legal
circles and fear in the intelligence community as
it effectively blocked officials from assessing
the seized documents for national security risks.
But Cannon wasn't finished. She agreed to Trump's
request for a special master and appointed Raymond
Dearie, a well-respected federal judge. After
Deary tried to bring some discipline to the case.
Cannon immediately ran interference for Trump,
overruling an order that would have required
the former president to either disavow or stand
by previous claims that FBI agents were planted
at Mar a Lago. And this goes on and on and on. And
Mark Joseph Stern then gets to the critical part.
Imagine that Cannon does preside over this case.
She has infinite tools at her disposal to thwart
the prosecution at nearly every turn. Big
swings like tossing out the whole case,
very real possibility. And her courtroom of chaos
can be appealed and overturned. But at every step,
there are opportunities for sabotage. Cannon
can try to rig voir dire to help the defense
stack the jury with Trump supporters. She
can exclude evidence and testimony that's
especially damning to Trump. She can disqualify
witnesses who are favorable to the prosecution.
She can sustain the defense's frivolous objections
and overrule the prosecution's meritorious ones.
She can direct a verdict of acquittal to rendered
the jury superfluous. She can declare a mistrial
prematurely for any number of reasons. I think
you get it. So the back stop here and a couple
of lawyers wrote to me and said, you know, David,
everything that's being written about what I lean
can and can do is true. It's not wrong. But it
ignores that there are checks and balances from
other judges that the prosecution could recur
to if necessary. And it is not as scary as some
of these articles are making it out to be. It's
still scary, but just not quite as scary as some
articles are making it out to be. We're going to
be following the Aileen Cannon sort of narrative
and story because it is actually a potentially
huge part of this prosecution. Maybe tomorrow,
probably more after the arraignment on
Wednesday, We will get back to this.